Bill Murray had trouble with fellow
castmates but you don't know who you're
gonna get nice Bill Murray you're gonna
get the tough Bill Murray Rob Schneider
didn't hold back when talking about his
Time with Bill on SNL telling Sirius
xm's the Jim Norton and Sam Roberts show
the 72 year old had quote naked rage and
hatred for other comedians on set he's
super nice to fans he wasn't very nice
to us absolutely hated a Seer I mean
seething he hated Chris Farley with a
passion and he hated Sandler really
hated Sandler too this isn't the first
time bill has been called out Lucy Liu
Drew Barrymore and Richard Dreyfuss have
all spoken about their issues with the
star and most recently production on
Aziz ansari's feature film being mortal
was shut down after Bill was accused of
inappropriate behavior with a female
staffer bill has reportedly settled with
his accuser for a little over one
hundred thousand dollars everybody knows
bills yesterday Seth Green claimed bill
is the rudest celebrity he's ever met
alleging to the Good Mythical Morning
Show he was once the target of Bill's
wrath at SNL when he was just nine years
old he picked me up by my ankles held me
upside down he dangled me over a trash
can and he was like the trash goes in
the trash can and I was screaming this
weekend the NBC show is serving up a hot
girl Saturday night
ah yeah Megan the stallion is pulling
double duty as host and musical guest I
want that nasty that freaky stuff the
show ain't written yet nope but it's
already Thursday yep and in sad news
beloved Harry Potter star Robbie
Coltrane has passed away the 72 year old
who played Hagrid had been sick for the
past two years and looked frail during
the reunion special so you could be
watching 50 years time easy
I'll not be here sadly
Haggard well